hello everyone and welcome to the
long-awaited Q&A video basically all of
you that used hashtag question will
probably see a question here although
there were a lot of similar questions a
lot of the questions were actually the
same so I filtered them out and for
example a lot of you asked what is
what's my dog's name so I will only
answer one of those questions obviously
and if you're if your question is for
some reason not here then it's probably
due to a topic I'm not willing to
discuss on this channel such as politics
or I simply missed it so if if that's
the case I might have missed your
question then just write it in the
comments and I will answer it in this
video so let's get started there are a
lot of questions as I really didn't
expect so many questions so let's let's
not waste time first question when
handed when and then what what country
did just get invented I have no idea but
I don't think that's like unknown fact I
know that some historians say that it
came from India some say that it came
from Persia although I read a book about
chess history and did they say that
there were even some chess pieces found
dating the second century in Italy so
it's hard to say if they were chess
pieces or maybe just ornaments but I
don't think that that the origin of
chess is like a known fact is honored
the best player of all times
well I am definitely not qualified to
say who is the best player of all times
but he is definitely one of the best
what are your future plans for this
channel
well my future plans for the channel are
to grow it very very large maybe have
some grandmasters over maybe maybe have
some videos with them maybe even
organize some tournaments and have a
live broadcast but definitely one of one
of my most important plans is to have
like a million subscribers and then I
can make an official petition to feed a
stating that they have to grant Russia
a grandmaster title so that's one of the
plans at what age did you start playing
chess well my grandfather who was a
philia master he taught me the rules
when I was like four or five but I I
never I played the like from five to
seven and then I completely forgot about
just lie was like 17
then I again started playing a bit and
then I think I joined the Chess Club
when I was about 19 who do you expect to
be in the next world champion I have no
idea who do I expect to be the next
world champion but I do expect Carlsen
to defend his title after this candidate
series can you recommend me some of your
favorite books about chess well the
books about chess that I mostly read
were not so much about studying chess
but were more mostly chess biographies
so I will recommend my friend Bobby
Fischer by the material it's up to
everyone it's really an enjoyable book
especially if you like Fischer and
mostly all of his books are great boris
spassky on the move and if you're like a
total beginner I would definitely
recommend the chess fundamentals by
Capablanca that I also started with that
book so of course I will recommend it
where do you live not your address and
where are you from I live in Croatia in
a very small town
it's called creativity it's like 60
kilometers from the capital of Croatia
from Zagreb do you by any chance know
about any famous chess players that also
studied med school I I know I I can't
say that I do I I'm pretty sure I don't
know any famous chess players that
studied in med school Morphy studied law
but I don't know about med school how
often do you compete and / can a young
player like me sign up to compete well
first of all I don't know how young you
are but you know you're never too young
to compete if you're you know if you're
willing to lose a few games but I don't
compete that often especially now you
know in my younger days maybe something
years ago I did play about maybe two to
three tournaments a year but now I'm
to play only my chess club championship
as that's very close to me and it's very
convenient I couldn't really afford to
go play tournaments or to go abroad or
something like that your favorite
opening from both both sides obviously
well hard to say I for every game I
prepare I prepare different opening that
that way I make the game interesting for
me but I don't know what white I guess I
enjoy playing the Evans gambit pretty
much people know that and as black I
don't know
as black I die I'm probably I'll
probably always play e5 and go for the
Petrov defence but you know I know well
in all of my games in my chess club
championship now as black I played b6
Owens defense so maybe maybe that's my
new favorite do you play any modern
board game with a chest like feel no I
can say that I do although some more
than 10 years ago I tried a board game
called Excalibur it's something like
chess but all the pieces are the same
unless you see behind the piece of what
the piece is actually about and only if
you attack it you can see what it is and
then you have to remember what it is for
the rest of the game so it's not really
complicated but I did find it quite
enjoyable would you rather play a
hyperbolic game with Tull or a crazy
house game with Carlsen well as Carson
is still alive I would rather do
anything with Tull if the opportunity
presented itself favorite South American
chess player favorite South American
chess player I want to say neither but
he's from Poland
he later he only later came to Argentina
but I don't know probably Enrique making
as he really didn't make his mark in the
world if it wasn't for his unfortunate
disease illness he probably would have
gotten really far what aspect of Russian
has made you know
bleh was so strong that Michael Todd
found so hard to beat I don't know if
that's actually the case here like I
said in my videos of the four games they
played where she'd had the white pieces
in all of the games and III think even
if tal found a way to refute his ideas
he didn't want to spoil the combination
as you know a to tal that was that was
worse than losing
I'd say can you do a couple of videos
about the of the Evans gambit and Paul
Morphy yeah I mean I definitely could
what's your favorite beer my favorite
beer is actually the one they make here
in my hometown in creative it's called
critical people or critical beer so
that's that's definitely my favorite
have you beaten Magnus 12 years old no I
tried to play one game but I am i
recording was interrupted by someone and
haven't haven't tried it since and I
didn't really think I could do it like
waiting out the moves like it did the
previous ages although I didn't really
blitz out age 11 age 11 took me
something 10 minutes if I remember
correctly but I will definitely get back
to it best opening book for beginner I
don't well I don't think that beginners
should study openings at all when I
started learning chess I only had one
book for openings there was the theory
of theory of openings by Boris Labiche
both and it was in two parts one was
open and semi open games and one was
about close games so that's the only
book well does the only book I actually
ever used to study openings probably why
my opening knowledge is really bad when
did you start playing chess and why
that's a really difficult question
I started playing chess like I said when
I was about 17 years old because we were
at a playground and a friend of mine
challenged me to a game saying that he
can beat me in seven moves in the end I
accepted the challenge because I even
though I didn't play chess and
I know the rules and in the end I want
that game so that kind of got me
interested seems like you know I haven't
played for a very long time but I can
win a game so that's about time I
started playing when I was 17
how do you pronounce your handle you
pronounce it
I got motto like like it's you know like
it's written
I got matter can I know your chest
rating my current chest rating my
national rating is around 2000 and maybe
60 or 70 but my Iloilo is really low
it's about 900 1,900 and maybe something
but I don't really play any
international tournaments to actually
play for ello when when I only earned my
elo it was about 2050 but then I played
like that one terrible tournament and I
was like a hundred and fifty points and
it stayed like that ever since what was
your best ever rating well my best
illo was the one I got when I actually
got my low rating I think it was around
250 and my best national rating was if I
remember correctly 2,095 I remember I
was like a couple of points from winning
my candidate master title but and never
got to it
I wonder who thought you chess yeah I
already answered that it was my
grandfather
Antonia also from kinesiotape he was a
feedom master in Croatia and he really
played chess like all the time how did
you get so good at chess well I don't
know where you get your facts sir but I
never I never heard got good at chess
what do you think of go what do you like
chess more I like just more because I'm
familiar with chess I'm not familiar
would go and I never actually met anyone
in person that that knew how to play go
to maybe teach me or something any
advice for the first tournament well
don't don't beat yourself about it and
you know just to go play some games it
doesn't matter if you lose
all the games you lose when you start
playing chess they will be useful for
you after you analyze them and you will
eventually get better as they say the
best way to get better is to actually
play the games bishop or a knight well
I'm definitely a bishop man and even in
positions where it seems like Knight
would have a slight advantage I will
probably still pick a bishop as you know
I don't mind like waiting two hours for
the position to open up to maybe I only
then activate my bishop unless the
knight like really has an advantage I
think I'll always pick a bishop have you
ever heard of Kasparov's masterclass if
so what do you think of it yes of course
I mean who hasn't heard about as far as
masterclass I've never seen it as I
don't know I've never never had the
opportunity to see it anywhere and I
haven't purchased one but as Kasparov
says it's it's I mean you're getting the
lessons from Garrick as part of himself
I think he said that if you're below
1800 e low that it will be useful for
you how did you get the name agate
matter
well that that will still remain a
mystery and maybe I will answer this on
some other milestone do you have any
recommendations for beginners yes
studied the endgame don't study the
openings and try to understand chess
principles as as best as you can
any good chess books to read air every
chess book is good I don't know if
you're a total beginner like I said I
always recommend chess fundamentals by
Capablanca but I also hear anything by
Jeremy Suleiman is good although I've
never read any of his works myself and
yeah if you're if you're a bit more
experienced you're you know maybe at a
level where you want to sharpen your
tactics and maybe you know even start
creating a game plan then one of the
best best books I've ever read was
strategy and tactics by grigory me
high-low each listen it's a book in
three parts one is about you know really
sharp tactics the one is about like
middle game tactics or something like
that and the part three is a finding
finding a game plan so it was a but
you'll need a lot of time if you're not
gonna like read it and for an entire day
I think it took me about a year and a
half like when I was traveling from
currency to Zagreb everyday by train I
used like that time maybe an hour or if
the train was late maybe even two hours
to read that book do you think there are
too many draws in the chess tournaments
and that this is something that should
be addressed maybe by employing soccer
pointing system three points for win one
point each for draw zero points for
losing the game I as this is something
that was discussed many times I don't
think it would actually decrease the
number of draws but it would definitely
make for example games that are closer
to the end of the tournament more
interesting as if someone was behind two
points then you definitely can use that
win and maybe it will then employ a very
sharp opening so it might get it might
get the game it's more interesting and I
kind of think they will employ this
system in the future what is your dog's
name the dog's name is meadow it's like
an EPO it means a bear in Croatian or
maybe little bear
but yeah it's metal although some people
actually think it's metal like an
English English word but it's not do you
have a favorite chess game well I mean
choosing the favorite chess game is like
impossible but if I had to pick one
right now I I would definitely choose an
urge Medina of versus chair Nico of in
1962 that a wonderful Queen sacrifice on
f6 if you haven't seen it you can check
it out on my channel under the greatest
Queen sacrifice in chess history whether
it's the greatest Queen chatter
sacrifice in chess history maybe not
what you know I really like it and it's
my favorite do you have a story do you
say hello everyone when interacting with
people in your life and no as people we
run from don't speak English so that
would be quite weird what do you what do
you like to do in your free time
other than chess well basically
everything
you know enjoy walks with meadow enjoy
spending quality time with Jelena enjoy
playing video games I mean who doesn't
and you know a lot of things going out
for a beer yeah a lot of stuff what is
your favorite the game outside chess
well I don't know what you mean by game
but I don't know I guess I guess I could
say Texas Hold'em I really enjoy poker
have you ever played a game blindfold
yes I have played blindfold games mostly
for fun and mostly when you're out with
someone having a beard but you know if
I'm playing a weaker player I will win a
blindfold game but a stronger player not
so much but then again I'm not gonna win
against the strongest player even
without playing blindfold what is your
favorite chess piece to use I have no
idea I think only I'm pretty sure only
children have favorite pieces but if I
had to choose I would definitely go for
the rook as you can always make a nice
rook lift do you still work out yes I
don't go to the gym anymore I do some
home exercises at home but I've been
definitely planning to go back to the
gym probably very soon what would you
say is the most important thing to learn
as a beginner I think it's definitely
the most important thing to do is to
learn the endgame and the general chess
principles definitely not the openings
what do you do for a living well I
worked as a graphic designer
in a local company for like 4 years but
as of October last year I quit my job
and now I only do YouTube what would you
say is the most important thing to learn
as a beginner yeah I think we already
have that had that sorry if you would
face a grandmaster who would you like to
play white or black and what opening I
don't know I would definitely enjoy a
game with Devon choke and I wouldn't
really care if I was white or black or
what opening it was could you show us a
chart of the growth of the number of
subscribers from when you began the
channel until now well I could but then
again that information is publicly
available to everyone you can just go to
social blade type of a matter and you
can see all the statistics regarding my
channel you're interested in alright
yours is the only channel featuring a
dog what made you decide to include
meadow in your videos well I never
decided to include him in the videos
he just started appearing by himself as
he doesn't really have any restrictions
where he can go and not go in the
apartment so for some reason he always
gets behind me when I do the videos for
example now he's not he's like sleeping
here next to me but you know if he
decides to he really likes the couch
sorry we're worried which is your
favorite video which was the hardest to
do which was the easiest I don't have a
favorite video all of them or you know
some of them have more blunders some of
them have less blunders but you know I
don't have a favorite one none of them
were really hard to do and none of them
were really particularly easy to do some
of them did require a bit more research
but you know the pinpoint an individual
video I don't think I could do that
which video received the most views the
most views I believe was the video I
titled Bobby Fischer beats a grandmaster
in 10 moves which is very unfortunate
because that game Fischer didn't beat
the grandmaster in 10 moves but that was
like the first video I made on YouTube
in in this style where I have the board
and I like analyze the moves and I was
doing that video from memory and for
many many years I thought that that game
actually lasted 10 moves and that
Reshevsky surrendered I mean that he
resigned in that position but in the end
I realized that that that game lasted
like 42 moves so that was very
unfortunate but yes that video has the
most views and probably it's the biggest
blunder I ever made while making a video
how has making YouTube videos affected
your social life well don't
it really affected it I don't know
people talk to me more about YouTube but
you know I still see the same people you
know go for a beer with the same people
so it hasn't really affected my social
life do you feed Meadow dry dog food do
you feed him corn based dog food or some
other kind of special diet well not
really made of metal it's only you know
not nice food that that for example
humans would eat nice vegetables not
really vegetables but he eats meat for
example the same meat humans would eat
and you know pretty much sometimes I buy
him some special food but then he
doesn't want to eat it for a couple of
days he's very picky sometimes he will
eat the decent not that so there's
there's really no no rule to this how
cuz making of chess videos affected your
style of playing chess well if anything
it worsened it as as for as long as I'm
making just videos in YouTube I don't
know I think my my playing strength
maybe has improved and I take more care
about every move but at some point for
example I lost my last game in my chess
club championship because I I created
the winning position and then I
completely stopped thinking about the
game I started thinking about other
things maybe what video I'm going to do
today and in the end that resulted in me
actually worsening my position then the
position was a draw and then I wanted to
forcefully win it which ended in me
losing the game which was in the end
fair but yeah it definitely affected it
how much time does it take to make a
chest video well it depends sometimes
you need like a 10-minute preparation if
there's like not a big story behind the
game and maybe if it's a short game 20
moves
25 moves but if it's a maybe 45 moves or
50 moves and there is a lot to talk
about behind the game maybe
little research it depends it can range
from I guess ten minutes to an hour and
a half it depends on how focused you are
I'm studying it and analyzing it I
noticed a big improvement from the
earlier video says anyone advised you or
helped you in improving your channel
well every one of you probably advised
me on how to improve my channel as you
know whenever someone you post a comment
you you always say how to improve
something so I don't do everything but
for example I remember someone in my
earlier videos said that he would very
much enjoy if there were actually photos
and not photos pictures of the players
next to the board so I added that and in
the end it all worked out and you know
little by little with your suggestions
this is the this is the final result
what's your opinion on Maurice Ashley he
took a lot of heat for the smooth
incident but he's also a longtime GM who
has been successful in bringing chess to
the masses and getting people excited
about the game do you think that awkward
interview has ruined his reputation well
no I I for one really enjoy his
commentary he's a very lovely guy and I
don't think that one awkward moment
ruined his reputation as I don't think
one awkward moment can ruin anyone's
reputation you know if you if you judge
someone based on one awkward moment then
that's like that's like not cool
so now I don't I don't think you did
what is the best way how to learn to
play better well play long games like if
you play online then play at least 15
min 15-minute games and analyze your
games afterwards and then you know just
maybe don't use a certain opening but
use a certain system something you enjoy
something you like playing and then try
to try to get better at it
have you played material each on YouTube
if not would you play him and make each
and each make a video I have never
played them but sorry I would definitely
enjoy playing against motto motto is a
legend after
how do you think that we can all dispel
the misconception that chess is some
magical game that requires genius level
of thinking I don't think just it's a
magical game that requires some genius
level of thinking I think it's like in
every other sport art or anything you
know you can just put a little effort
into it and you will get little little
results but if you really put yourself
into it the results will be of course
greater again we have what does a good
motto mean for time being for the time
being I will leave that a mystery what
are your three favorite gambits well as
I really enjoy all the gambit speaking
only three would be very hard but I
would definitely have the the Evans
gambit the Kings gambit but I don't play
the Kings gambit there often now because
you know people just play the four bears
counter gambit so for number three I
will use for bears counter gambit Kings
gambit so that's probably my top three
can you tell a brief history about
yourself well you know what's a brief
history I went to school I went to high
school you know I didn't really have any
problems in school I went to college I
first I tried studying law school but
didn't really care for it so then I
tried graphics design but didn't really
care for that either and third I tried
like computer science or informatics
however you call it I did finish first
year of college but then I like lost
interest in it so you know then I
started working I've been you know
besides work I've been also shooting
weddings for like ten years so on the
weekends
but you know now after all of that I'm
at this point in my life where I'm just
doing this and you know see see where it
takes me do you and your girlfriend have
plans to have kids yes definitely do you
think you'll analyze more women's chess
matches in the future well I don't
analyze games based on whether they were
played by a man or
woman rather than how what if the game
was interesting and how strong the
player that played it was but you know
it's not like a lot of your suggestions
don't really suggest games played by
women chess players so but I think I
showed plenty you know have you ever
thought of collaborating with another
chess channel well yes I've thought
about a total I don't think anyone ever
asked me so but you know I don't know
how we could would collaborate if we
were to meet up in person and then
create something like some content
that'd be pretty cool but like making a
video together you know everyone at his
own computer don't doesn't really I
don't really see the point of it but
playing against someone else yet that
would definitely be enjoyable are you
ever going to make any videos analyzing
games sent in by your subscribers yes I
definitely will I'm still going over
them has your left handedness ever
affected your gameplay or sportsmanship
I don't really know how to answer to
this but there is one good side of being
left-handed when you're a chess player
as most people are right-handed you will
never argue with your opponent whether
the clock will be on the left or on the
right in some tournaments the arbiter
will you know say that it has to be on
the right so that he can always see what
time it is on the clock but at some
tournaments that there there is no rule
like that so you will have to agree with
your opponent it's usually that the the
player would the black pieces he gets to
choose where the clock is but you know
if there's not that rule and if your
opponent is very rude for example then
you could argue but you know if you're a
left-handed person then it's all good
I've been playing chess for some time
now but I like the strength in
identifying a bad move and how to
capitalize on that well there's a really
no quick way to get through this it's
like something you would call a tactics
alarm or a chess alarm you know
something like spider-man has
when he senses tingling simply play and
with time you will develop this alarm
how long have you been playing chess and
what motivates you to do it what it's
very hard to answer what this plank just
mean does it mean playing actively in
tournaments playing like any opportunity
you get playing online like bullet games
but you know all in all I've been
playing since I was like 17
so roughly 13 years what motivates me to
do it well I really enjoy it it's really
the best motivation you can get why do
we always find out it was a stupid move
to make just after we made it well
sometimes you don't it's mostly due to
the fact that your opponent will punish
your bad move or your mistake but
actually I've seen a game played by Josh
Waitzkin it was some junior USA
championship and left his rook hanging
like he just left the rook and his
opponent could simply capture the rook
and it's game over but his opponent
didn't see it nor did Josh he just moved
the rook for the on the next move but he
didn't even realized he left it hanging
it was only after the game they told him
and he was like what but he won the
championship so that was pretty cool how
long have you been playing okay we saw
that did you name your daughter meadow
because it means fear in Portuguese or
for another reason
I had no idea what meadow means in
Portuguese but I didn't name him either
he was actually a dog and my girl he was
a he was actually owned by my
girlfriend's parents but they had to go
a leave country they had to go work in
Germany so we decided that we will take
care of meadow sorry do you plan on
returning to professional level at the
moment no I would have to really take my
time you know get back into chess to
really you know I would have to prepare
nicely like for for a month month and a
half and go to some strong tournaments
to just get back into playing and I
would probably play the tournament
terrible so maybe on the second
tournament I would go to I could maybe
gain some results when is your birthday
and how old are you at the moment I'm
thirty years old and my birthday is on
16th of June how many hours do you do
something related to chess in a day I
don't know probably like half a day you
know as I do have a lot of comments to
go through your games you sent me your
photos you sent me so that that takes up
a lot of my time as you know I really
appreciate the interaction between you
guys and myself but yeah roughly half a
day sometimes even more you know when I
was covering the world blitz and rapid
championship even an entire day when is
your okay sorry event for Coulson oh
that's like I mean Carson is still too
young to be featured anywhere you know
he can be featured in maybe ten years I
will always be Killing Joke what is your
favorite gambit to play how about the
play against well once again it's
probably the Evans gambit and to play
against probably the forebear gambit to
the Kings gambit when you started the
channel did you get support from friends
and family or did you continue despite
some uncertainties from other people
well I think anyone who ever started the
channel will tell you that and no one
actually thought that was a particularly
good ideas bench especially if you
really put a lot of time into it in mine
in my case my girlfriend was very
supportive you know she always enjoyed
when I you know put put some and put
some time into something but most other
people would tell you that you know
that's that's very cute but I don't
think that's like gonna work or
something so if you ever decide to make
a youtube channel you know ignore anyone
who doesn't boost your confidence any
chance one of the Great's will willingly
sorry
any chance one of the greats is willing
to make a video with you about one of
their games
I will definitely enjoy that although
unfortunately many of the greats are
very rarely hearing creation because
prob is actually here quite a lot so
I might get him at some point to join me
if you had the choice and the time
machine which chess player would you
like to have a match with well all of
them really
how many grandmasters have you played
over the board in classical chess I only
played one and if you seen that game on
my channel but online like in blitz and
Bullitt and you know any short time
formats I really have no idea when will
we get a video about your dog to see you
playing with him I don't really see the
purpose of such a video but I do have
some photos of meadow and on Instagram
and I don't have a nice video of him I
could upload so maybe you can check that
out as a meadow it really doesn't like
to be photographed it's it's very rare
that I photograph meadow
he's like afraid of everything you know
bottles of cell phones he's like he's
like a really weird dude will you
finally tell us what a good matter means
yes I will but not in this video that is
still to remain a mystery is the world
if the world was a chessboard who is the
king now that is really the question
well if the world was just boarded first
of all I guess there would have to be
two kings but you know who those kings
be I really couldn't say it doesn't
really matter you know the King needs
pieces and pawns to protect him if it's
a allows the king then they'll just get
rid of him what do you think of four
player chests I've seen it but I can say
I really enjoyed it
never never actually played it how is
the island of nits I've never actually
been there myself but I I hear it's
quite lovely it's good you know it
doesn't have a lot of people so you know
it has to be lovely it has quite quite a
beautiful land sites you know I think
there are like a thousand people leaving
living there have you ever made your own
chess set well one that I can remember I
was some 10 years ago in Zagreb with a
friend and we couldn't find any chess
sets the bite there was like no chess
set anywhere to buy
so we made our own out of cardboard and
we we made the board and we even cut out
to two spots for you know beer or coffee
or whatever you like which is but only
the board not the pieces yeah we had the
pieces only the board which is your most
memorable chess match that you lost
can't can't really remember most
memorable that I lost
hmm well I did play
I did play I did play a game it was uh
it was I believe it was the creation
team chess to Croatian team championship
finals I'm I think it was a game against
Marco boss eh not really sure I'm Erin's
brother and I played the Evans gambit
against him and it was like maybe it
moves six or moves seven he took like 45
minutes to the side on the move and he
played I'm pretty sure he never faced
the Evans gambit like in in classical
chess and it really took him a long time
to answer and finally when he did my
position was still was still you know
decent but then I like completely ruined
it
and I lost the game of course and I was
I was very sad because I was very happy
when I saw him thinking for like 45
minutes and he was much much much higher
rated than me maybe even to 200 or more
yellow points high rather than me
so that could be most memorable not
match but game that I lost do you plan
on making more special videos like the
top 10 facts about X chess players yeah
I definitely enjoyed making those and I
will definitely make more at some point
when I really don't know
have you considered doing a series on
openings well a lot of you asked me this
but there are so many videos about
openings and YouTube I don't see how I
could contribute you know to making a
series about openings maybe I could do a
series on the
gambits or something like that but on
openings I'm sure there are plenty of
videos on YouTube already have you sorry
if you could receive private lessons
from any living chess player who could
it be from a living chess player
probably again vasily von Schuch that
would be like like an epic lesson what
is your favorite Croatian beer favorite
Croatian beer is as I don't really like
bottled beers I would I would have to
say the one made in my hometown in Crete
see the creature watch puppy oh that
would have to be my favorite beer what
books or methods do you prefer for me to
improve my tactics and strategy well the
only one I used for tactic and strategy
I will repeat it again its strategy and
tactics by grigory me hallo ich listen
it's quite a quite a lovely book I mean
three books actually when participating
in a tournament
made up of stronger players than
yourselves how do you prepare well the
best player the best tournament to play
in is the one where all the players are
stronger than you then you really have
nothing to lose you can prepare for
every game you will have a lot more
material to use you know there are a lot
more games if your opponents are
stronger they will have a lot more games
online you can download them you can
study their openings and they will have
far less information about you so you
can use that in your advantage and you
know be brave attack and you know hope
hope for the best
how about hosting an online tournament
more often for your subscribers yes
that's that's definitely not a bad idea
and I always say that I will do this but
then something always gets in the way
but I will I will try and make it I
always say I will like once a week
but something always interrupts me but I
should really really take care of that
how long it moves was the longest chess
game you had ever played probably around
100 moves I don't think it was over 100
as there are 60 moves that can fit into
a sheet and I'm pretty sure I used two
sheets but not
not so so much so I think less than 100
sorry have you ever heard of a chess
player named a rusty Shackleford rusty
Shackleford no I can't say I have but I
will definitely google him what is your
favorite beer wine or vodka a beer of
course I'm totally a beer man but since
you didn't put rakia here
but even if Erica was here I would also
choose beer as you know beer is beer do
do you play that did you play chess in
school is just the thought regularly in
Croatia in schools
I haven't myself but some some some did
as I never actually even knew that we
had it wasn't really a chess club it was
more like chess our you know instead of
going to the gym you could go play chess
but I never actually even but even if I
knew I don't think I would have now it's
it's it's not regular in Croatia schools
but with power of doing so much trying
to get chess into schools it might
actually soon very well be the highest
feeder rated player you ever beat and
you ever played the highest-rated feed a
player I ever played was the one I
already made a video about you can check
it out on my channel I think he was
right around 2500 and something and
highest-rated feed a player I ever beat
I believe was somewhere around I really
don't know as sometimes they show their
national ratings sometimes they're
yellow ratings but I think around 20 to
50 maybe 2300 do you have any children
no I don't even though a lot of you have
congratulated me for having kids on that
Rashid video but I don't what are your
top three books top three books I don't
know I will go for the my friend bobby
fischer by sending material science
since i don't know if
if you're asking about chess books I
will gladly also include The Selfish
Gene by Richard Dawkins and maybe
physics of Star Trek by Lawrence Krauss
that was also an interesting book so
let's go with those three why is the
Sicilian called Sicilian I have no idea
I think probably due to the place where
it was played and later you know they
just left it the name so I'm pretty sure
Google would know this why do you not
show games of Vishy Anand will actually
show a lot of games by Viswanathan Anand
there's even a playlist about two chuan
autonomous games on my channel you will
find a lot of his games there what game
of yours do you feel is the closest to
your immortal game well I remember one
game I played I actually even wanted to
find my notes about it but as we moved
we like changed five apartments so I
have no idea where my games are but it
was I had the black I had the white
pieces I was playing against the
candidate master and he played the
French against me and I remember I I
sacrificed like three pawns in the
opening and then I sacrificed like a lot
of the pieces and then India and
checkmate at risking in the center of
the board so that was that was very
enjoyable but I'm still not able to find
if I found if after I find out to where
my games are I will definitely show it
what are your top three chess players I
mean it's impossible for someone who who
who is in chess everyday to pick three
top chess player three chess players but
I will definitely put Anna Schmidt Dean
of tile and I will go with Capablanca
but then again I have to choose event
truck so I have no idea I will I will go
for tile news medina and avenge
definitely kappa blanka will go maybe if
there will be like a top five I don't
think there this doesn't have anything
to do with their strengths I just
they're just my top three chess players
who is the best chess player of all time
in your opinion and why well I think
best of all time is definitely in my
opinion
Jose roll Capablanca why well his
results speak for themselves and you
know even after losing his title to
awaken he still continued winning
tournaments
you know strongly but he never never
ever got his rematch with addiction so I
don't know I just I just think Blanco
was the strongest do you still smoke yes
I am considering quitting it but not
just yet what is the difference between
average player and a good player well I
believe an average player will be able
to play a great game but then will also
be able to play a really bad game and
the good player will be more consistent
in his games like he will maybe you know
those games that aren't really in his
style
maybe people draw them and those that go
his way he will win the windows games
for example you've seen my video how I
drew against an international master and
Wright who was raided around 2400 and
right after that game when I returned
the Kree shirt see we played our chess
club championship started and I was the
game against a 1600 player so that's
like the definition of non consistent hi
what do you think about shahi comment
are on hive day 3 do watch it
that's a chess show and on Croatian TV I
think it's I think it's great and I have
seen it a couple of times but as I don't
have a TV set in my apartment I don't
watch it like regularly watch maybe put
the towel picture in all of your videos
well you know he really deserves it
he was he was really great for a
beginning chess player what are a couple
of strong openings news in general I
don't know for a beginning chess player
you like I always say you shouldn't
study openings you should just
maybe decide are you are you an e4
player then choose the system with e4
that you enjoy and and choose like two
defenses for black one to e4 one to d4
but I don't know for like a total
beginner I would suggest you know just
play d4 Knight f3 Bishop c4 and see
where it takes you and then find your
own style and after a couple of games
you will already have an idea what you
liked and what you don't like okay does
your girlfriend likes chess there's a
girlfriend like chess and how does she
react on the amount of time you spend in
front of the computer well even before I
did YouTube I spent a fair amount of
time in front of the computer but yes
she actually likes just very much and
she plays chess herself when she was
younger she played just a lot more even
competitively at one point she won't she
won't second place with her team in in
the and finals of that was like creation
school championships so yeah shoes she
played competitively and but then like
after maybe she was 15 then she didn't
play so much anymore but she enjoys it
and her into her family plays it both of
her brothers play it
her father plays it so they're really
like a really big chess family alright
we know have you ever done a positional
queen or rook sacrifice in a serious
games I'm pretty sure I've never done a
positional Queen sacrifice I've done a
lot of Queen sacrifices that would win
me a lot of material or maybe win the
game but no I don't think I've ever done
a positional Queen sacrifice that's like
four really strong players to do but
yeah I have done positional rook
sacrifices you know maybe to create a
nice pawn pawn chain or maybe to get rid
of an active piece and if your
opponent's rook was nothing in the
corner then it was justified I've always
wondered what are the key things to have
to play as beautiful as tall and still
have
Goodwyn rate well just to be as good a
style you have to like have really big
imagination really enjoy the game and
you have to like really be a master at
openings because you can't allow to have
you can't allow yourself to have
problems in the opening to lose a lot of
time because the play life style you
have to get your opponent's in time
trouble do you yourself being so great
you know in openings and the middle game
so those are probably just just a few
things what sports do you watch
generally I don't watch any sports I
will sometimes it's if it's like a
really important match I will watch me
me MMA or maybe I will watch a soccer
match if there's like to the world
soccer championship going on but like
all the time no not really and I think
we're at the last page very nice
do you think you will be able to become
even stronger well if I put some work
into it then perhaps but you know just
by making videos I don't think so what
is your favorite place to visit in
Europe I have no ideas I don't really
travel that much
I've only only went to a couple of
countries like I've been to Greece
Netherlands Germany and but that was
like a long time ago
so don't really have a favorite place
but I'm definitely planning on doing
some traveling maybe in the future have
you ever played with some Hungarian
chess players
yes I've played again some Hungarian
chess players is they they come quite
often in tournaments in Croatia what
chess engine do you use man well I use
depending on what what do I use it for I
don't really have any like like I don't
have stock fish or anything when I do my
videos I check the lines using simply
chess calm the one they provide how
satisfied are you with the chess scene
in Croatia well it could be definitely
could be better you know I'm not gonna
say it's not exist
and what it could definitely be better
how many couch covers do you own it
feels like that couch has been every
color Under the Sun not sure probably
around eight but you know we will always
get more because meadow really makes a
mess of them I'm a decent player in
longer time formats but it's bullet and
Blitzen terrible how can I improve my
speed chess games not sure because I
have the exact same problem I can play a
really decent game in like longer time
formats but in Blitzen bullet I'm like
terrible I contribute to this probably
to the fact that I might open opening
knowledge isn't that great so I have to
spend a lot of time so probably probably
that you know to be and you have to
understand positions that you play so I
don't waste a lot of time what are your
favorite neighboring countries neighbors
country country in neighboring countries
okay
I can't say I have any favorite
neighboring countries but I like some
three years ago I visited Bosnia and
Serbia for a couple of days and it was
very enjoyable how do you feel about
chess variants and relatives well I
don't really I don't really play them
but you know I I don't have like
anything against official random I know
some people enjoy a couple Blanca chess
but that would that really never you
know got to see the light of day
for player chess really not my thing and
I don't know if you ever heard of it but
there is a thing called pots of charcoal
so do Google that you know it's sort of
like chess but not really you don't play
to capture your opponent's king you
actually played to like make friends
with him and there's no capturing of the
pieces so this is like a new aspect to
the game how do you feel about okay do
you have interest in other competitive
games like go or bridge well those are
all games I wanted to learn at some
point but like I said I never actually
met anyone in person to play school or
bridge so never really got that
interested
actually learn it myself do you try to
memorize the games you show on your
YouTube channel well I don't try to
memorize them but when you go through it
and you have to analyze it and you know
you see it a couple of times it's you
know sticks would you ever be able to do
live commentary well of course I mean if
everyone would be able to do live
commentary but you know it would it
would it would only serve maybe
entertainment purposes as you know I I
couldn't analyze a game played between
top grandmasters yeah during the
high-level tournament is if there was a
way if there was if there was played
absolute perfect moves in chess from
start to the end in your opinion which
side would win black white or would it
be a draw well that's like the oldest
question in chess some people consider
it white would always win because he has
the advantage of the first move
some say it will definitely be a draw
but you know it actually might be that
black has the advantage maybe maybe
black has the advantage because white is
the first player that has the
opportunity to ruin the perfect position
from the start of the game maybe like
the starting position is like the mortal
choose one whoever moves first loses the
game so could be a lot of things what is
your biggest fear I I'm really terrified
of sea-weed you know if I if I go
swimming and there's some seaweed I'm
not going in there what do you think is
the best way for an absolute beginner to
learn the game and the theory with
limited time available I don't know game
and the theory would limit the time
available but just just enjoy it you
know and you use the time you have to
like study study something every day
like maybe here
study study a rockin game maybe study
King and pawn study night against Bishop
those are the things that matter where
do you where do you live who do you live
with what's your dog's name okay
I'm pretty sure I already answer that I
live in Croatia and create a live with
my girlfriend and the dog's name is made
of course and
are you a mid-laner I was but I don't
really play that actively anymore since
they reworked Katarina not really
interested the game changed so much I
can't keep up with it what music do you
listen to
I listen to all all music regardless of
the genre but you know everything that's
like quality but interestingly when I
work I mostly enjoy listening tonight
for that that kind of really stimulates
working how tall are you
last time I checked I was a hundred and
ninety-one centimeters I don't know
what's that in feet so you'll have to
you have to convert that how was your
life before you started making videos in
YouTube well pretty much the same I was
always doing some sort of videos as I
said I was I was shooting and editing
weddings for like ten years
so you know I was always making some
kind of videos only now only now I'm
making just videos what's your most
memorable experience that involves chess
well most memorable I remember when I
first joined the Chess Club they uh you
know they wouldn't let me to play for
the team so I first had to play the the
chess club championship and then if I
did well I get to play for the team and
then the first chess championship that I
chess club championship that I joined I
I think I got sixth place and they had
like six players for the team or maybe
even fifth place and they needed six
players for the team so then I you know
I got to make the team and I was very
happy about it you know I was feeling
very proud may chess be sometimes bad
because it causes dependence addiction
well I know a lot of players who spent
like every every free moment they have
you know going for just that one more
bullet game or one more hyperbolic game
and yeah probably it probably can be bad
but you know everything else can be bad
just just the same tips to improve
studied the endgame
have you ever chosen to
just rather than helping somebody you
care about no I can't say I have
what is your favorite soccer team I I
really don't have a favorite soccer team
where do you get your content from
mainly well mainly from from the books I
have many you know from or I just choose
any any big tournament played in history
or sometimes when I when I I'm not
covering anything at the moment I check
out your suggestions and if there's like
if there's like a live coverage you're
going on of some tournament for like for
example now the candidates will be
played so I will be covering the
candidates so you know a lot of a lot of
contents you know you really can't make
all the videos you want did you ever
think your channel would grow this big
well I don't know when you start making
videos for YouTube you you know your
channel always grows a little so you
know that it will continue growing you
know there will always be like one
subscriber per day maybe two subscribers
per day so you don't really think about
it and if you think about it I don't
think that you will you will enjoy doing
YouTube so I don't know but yeah if I
think like maybe a year ago no I I would
I would I would never have guessed do
you think towel would have been so great
if he didn't drink hard to say I don't
think his drinking was actually related
to how great his games were but would it
be better I I also have no idea maybe it
totally had no effect on his games you
know we can only speculate now or or
that's part of the magic yeah it could
be even that please suggest a stepwise
strategy or core structure to improve in
chess I'm sixteen hundred and seventy
rated on leeches if you're sixteen
hundred and seventy rated and leeches
studied the endgame you should you know
easily get to eighteen or nineteen
hundred just by you know studying the
endgame I would like to be a commentator
no not really you know when when you're
what
you're like making content like this you
know you're free to do whatever you you
enjoy if you're a commentator then you
have to have to keep the certain
guidelines and that's like I'm sure
that's not very enjoyable but I could be
wrong you know first I first thing I'd
have to improve my own chess a lot to
actually even try being a commentator
how did playing chess influenced your
everyday life and the moves you make
when you want to achieve something again
very hard to say as I've been playing
chess for most of my you know let's say
adult life since I was 17 so it's hard
to say what moves I would have been made
in my life if I wasn't playing chess do
you know any good chess book but on
Serbian or Croatian language well all
the books I actually mentioned were all
available in Serbian and Croatian the
chess fundamentals by capablanca that
chess chess theory opening theory by
boris l'viv Cove and the chess tactics
and strategy by recording me how elicits
in all of those books are available in
Croatian language and Serbian what is
your rank in league at the moment I
think I think last season I got the gold
but I don't know my best rank was
somewhere I think it was a gold one I I
got the qualifications for platinum but
never got to it not really I'm not
really a good player but you know if
things go my way I'm able to play a
decent game do follow materials chess
channel yeah I'm pretty sure I follow
mottos channels since like the beginning
I don't watch so much of his videos as I
have a lot of work to do myself but I
always check up on him money and how
he's doing how many Ehlo games have you
played again not sure but probably
around 50 maybe something less than 50
yeah definitely less than 50 or maybe
maybe around 50 yeah how do you prepare
yourself for every game you are about to
play well you have to
you know really like study study your
opponent study style studied the
openings he plays I prepare something
for him and you know get a lot of sleep
head you know really getting a good
night's sleep
is the most important thing when
preparing for a game watch Ashley the
last ikkaku Zagreb Illinois she drew a
great party great emotion per
participant amah it's a question in
creation will I ever come to Zagreb you
know to have a few beers with the fans
and play a few games
well definitely I've never actually been
invited by anyone you know to some sort
of a gathering or something but maybe I
will make a tournament but yeah probably
if I will be able I will make a
tournament and then I will invite you
all seems like a reasonable thing to do
how are you getting on with your Chess
Club Championship oh yeah maybe I don't
know if I mentioned it yeah I want a
championship I won first place although
I lost my last game that was very
unfortunate I will I will show it on my
channel although I will see maybe even
tomorrow I will see what I had planned
more of your games please okay it's a
deal now what is the most beautiful
place you have traveled to do like I
said I have never traveled much this
year I went to Germany too but Piermont
that's a very very nice place although
my girlfriend went in the summer and she
said that it's totally a different story
in the summer it's a lot a lot more
beautiful okay what other TV shows do
you watch other than Game of Thrones I'm
I really watch a lot of TV shows I very
much enjoy I don't know the black mirror
I'm a big fan of Spartacus I enjoy Star
Trek pretty much all of them probably
not Deep Space nine but you know lately
I have seen I've seen Orville Orville's
pretty cool what's that new one I just
saw it was a carbon Beyond or something
something about carbon about people you
know actually
wearing wearing bodies as suits so that
was pretty cool
but anything that has like sci-fi in it
you know just throw it my way I will
enjoy it
who will win the candidates in your
opinion well a lot of people are you
know saying our union will win it but
actually have a crazy theory that it it
could actually be Kuryakin that takes
the candidates again as after winning
last year's candidates he really didn't
do anything for an entire year and I
think this could may have be because he
has a guaranteed spot in the candidates
he doesn't have to try over the year so
he can simply save all of his secrets to
unleash them in the candidates so I
think he could actually be a very
dangerous opponent in the candidates
digital ever played blindfold chess I
don't know if he'll ever played
blindfold chess I can say I've ever
heard of toppling mindful chess I know
well you know a player doesn't blind
fold analysis now and then but I don't
remember him playing mindful chess but
I'm like fairly sure he did why lastly
one who isn't the best player of his
generation well you know there are there
were so many excellent players in that
generation but you know probably because
he's Chucky you know he can play a game
like a 3400 engine or you know sometimes
he he struggles with a 2,200 player I
told the pencil probably how he wakes up
what's your favorite beverage well
playing a tournament game
well it's if if it's an early tournament
or something I always enjoy coffee and
lots of water but if it's like you know
afternoon or an evening game then I will
maybe go maybe go for a soda or
something but always enjoy plenty of
water at what at any point were you
scared that you won't even hit hit
10,000 subscribers I know I never really
bothered myself with this as you know I
enjoyed the content I'm making I saw
people were joining them even when there
were very few people you know
the comments were very supportive and
you know I saw people enjoyed it so I
never really thought about it have you
ever played a musical instrument well I
played like I tried playing a lot of
instruments but mostly I played the
guitar I still have like an old electric
guitar I bought like 15 years ago
I think it's Yamaha yeah RG 121
something like that it's it's not a very
good one but you know for what I used
that it was quite enjoyable
hey we traveled abroad to watch or play
chess and if yes were and how was your
experience and no I've never actually
traveled abroad to play chess or to
watch it but I may be going to visit the
candidates this year but we'll see if it
will if it will be possible I would very
much enjoy that to maybe cover a few
games from there and to see it live what
is your favorite time control my
favorite time control for classical
chess is an hour and 30 minutes per
player plus 30 seconds increment per
move that's like the only classical time
control I enjoy and you know for online
games I enjoy hyper bullet-like
only 30 seconds no increment okay that
was the idea here that's that's that's a
good one
when do you think that young Misha will
earn the Grandmaster title
I feel referring to young Misha I was
suppose I don't know it's hard to say I
mean he's very very young and if he will
even stay interested in chess but you
know I feel if he keeps at it you know
he might do it like at 11 yeah you never
know
have you actually won any national
tournaments no I've never won a national
tournament other than my my chess club
championship but ya know just I believe
only my chess club championship my style
of play isn't really made for winning
tournaments you know I will play an
inter interesting game but it will not
be consistent I will also lose games
what are some changes improvements you
hope to make to your channel well I am
definitely considering upgrading you
know some of my equipment my my channel
design isn't really something you know
that's something I made a long time ago
not really impressed with it myself but
you know I it's not like I hate it or
anything but I would like maybe to
improve on that and the content wise
like I said I would very much enjoy if I
could bring some grandmasters to join me
in my videos and maybe even organize
some events later in the future what
inspired you to become a youtuber I
don't think anyone is inspired to become
a youtuber nor do I consider myself a
youtuber you know I just enjoyed
creating content very much and I was
just uploading it every day and you know
I saw people enjoyed it so I kept doing
it and yeah you know you watch a lot of
other YouTube channels so that kind of
impresses you a bit I guess I don't know
when I was playing league I was like I
remember I was watching The Voice
Channel a lot so maybe maybe even he
inspired me a little yeah definitely I
would say so I don't think there were a
lot of inspirations to it but mostly you
want to do something creative and
interesting and you know something
that's not like going to work every day
and you know it you want to avoid every
day being the same basically so yeah and
I actually think this is the last
question so I have no idea how long this
video lasts if any of you managed to you
know write it out to the end of the
video you know congratulations
do do honor yourself in the comments you
deserve it so I don't know I I do hope
you enjoyed this and I mean there your
questions I'm sorry there's so many of
them and like I said if I missed any of
them it's due to either being a topic I
wouldn't want discussed on my channel or
I simply missed your question so please
just you know write your question in the
comments and I will answer it so yeah
that's the that's the Q&A I do hope you
enjoy
as usual you can check - all my previous
videos here I think over watching and I
will see you soon